did she's an amazing heavyweight man he
stupid against eBay but who knows how
good John will be at heavyweight I've
seen with other heavyweights he wrecks
all he ragdolls [ __ ] he's a beast man
nice and he's walking around a natural
234 right every bit of it John's also
get an Old Earth oh man what's like cow
disease 31 32 miles on him though he's
got a lot of miles he slowed down a tad
let's just call it what it is it's what
you gotta wonder how much of that
slowing down is his enthusiasm how much
of is physical look I mean right yeah I
mean maybe if a big fight comes up like
a steep MeOH I know or Frances you're
right you're right and that I said yeah
you're right
I I go back and front heel maybe Sloane
dad's getting older and I go or maybe he
just doesn't give a [ __ ] about these
contenders he's fighting and you know
he's out partying got a super ball and
then he's like here the week before the
fight he's at the Super Ball he can't
fly you know beat them again cool yeah
fight yawn what yeah weird
yeah let's do it but then he hey you got
Francis you make one wrong move and you
get knocked out I bet we see a [ __ ]
gnarly ass John Jones he had a couple of
years off because involves troubles
outside of the Octagon right two years
we really wasn't fighting but other than
that he's had nine solid years against
World Championships although they never
did anything to him no money he never he
never told justice until one fight where
he didn't train Gustafson just didn't do
one fight and [ __ ] yes that's basically
know that he's yeah you're right he
starts to everybody hurt his elbow on
Matt Hamill face he's never been knocked
down right no never been knocked down I
mean he slipped against Thomas by
Dominic hit him in the chest and knocked
him down but it wasn't a knockdown like
Tyson Fury Deontay Wilder you know
wasn't that kind of nice that's been
took him down that was doing to him he
got taken down is that the only time
yeah DC didn't take him down No yeah I'm
excited to see that rematch I think I
think Dominic Reyes would be even better
in the rematch
I think Dominic Reyes realizes now it's
all about having the energy in that
third floor
and fifth round and haven't I already
been to the top of the mountain and and
face the dragon I think he's gonna come
back by the now there's the thing that
dragon and rematches gets way better and
goes oh you're an actual threat I'm
gonna prepare for it this time yeah he
[ __ ] dudes up and rematches yes offense
starts DC starts oh yeah yeah I'd like
to see it I want to see what Rhea's can
do to andreas race got that rub now
right raze is gonna come into that
second fight knowing that he came a a
[ __ ] hair away from being the light
heavyweight champion here and you know I
mean one judge gave it to John four
rounds to one which is nothing
embarrassingly bad like I owned the MMA
gym as well
what's so hilarious that crazy well he
also get off his nuts yeah it's just a
song Jesus doesn't make anything out you
know what people just look at fights
differently sometimes you know what I
mean because back you know there's dudes
look at rounds where even to this day
where a guy gets taken down and he
doesn't do any damage but he you know
and they'll still give it to the guy on
the bottom just cuz the guy on top
didn't do any damage you know to me and
then there's uh guys that for sure no
matter what if you get a takedown you're
gonna win the round
the other guy didn't gonna take down
right and there's guys that I mean in
the early 2000s that I knew some judges
I don't want to say any names but they
would give up they would give around to
a dude who escaped a bunch of
submissions because that guy had him in
great positions and he couldn't play his
game he couldn't implement his game and
he had all this great position on him
had his back in the escape so I'm gonna
give it to the guy who escaped like
Shane show yeah there's there's guys
like that out there so it's not
necessarily that you know the
retardation was it Ricardo him out I'll
meet a judge for a second he was and
he's just thought he's like I [ __ ] this
nice he's too busy successful school